[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
20 international chess professionals
compete in st. Louis as US chess champs
comm presents the second annual winter
chess classic welcome to st. Louis where
we present to you the winter chess
classic you are looking here at a live
shot of the players competing in the
round upstairs and as it starts to snow
here a little bit in st. Louis we've
been having a little bit of white
frosting on the ground we are greeted by
some heated games up here in the
boardroom and joining you here in the
studio I will be the guest host today
filling in for mr. Ben Simon who is out
for the weekend I'm Jonathan Chauncey
I'll be here today and tomorrow Ben
Simon will be back on Monday and Tuesday
to finish up the broadcast for the show
and I am joined by somebody grandmaster
jessie cry nobody in the world I'd
rather do commentary with so I am
delighted to be here yeah happy to have
you here and you know one announcement
we should make right away is Ben who is
away for the weekend you know he's a
famous guy this guy is out doing
commentary announcing we should call
it's no longer commentary it's
announcing for a pro wrestling event yes
he does very interesting stuff in his
free time and so it's fantastic that he
gets the chance to get out there and we
will miss him and I'm hoping that when
he comes back on Monday comes back with
the full paint yeah I know nacho or some
correct yeah nothing else would be
acceptable for maybe I'll come and so
with that we do also welcome everybody
that was watching the World Championship
today so we had another draw in Game two
a little bit shorter than the last one
do you have any thoughts about the game
that you saw today sure let me pull up a
board here and I'll walk you through
this now this is actually a board that
has different people's names on it but
that's everything you understand I'm
gonna just show one critical position
that I make this was here with the white
pieces today yeah
thank you and one critical position I
thought was really interesting and that
is in this situation here this is a
thing that's been going on since I was a
kid this precise position right here
after rook e1 and the first time anyone
sees this position they say themselves
black is beautiful he's got this what
seems like a development advantage and
the white King is on castle there's this
pin but then you start looking closer
this Bishop is a problem and if he can't
get out that rook is a problem so this
is a very well known position and Bobby
played rook d8 which feels like a Patzer
move
naca has played rook e8 Bishop e7 was
the move when I was a kid so rook t8 a
very funny movement you know Carlson
gave him a look and I don't want to
dwell too long in this game but I just
wanted to give my two cents in this
position that Carlson thought a little
bit and played Bishop e2 which is a
little bit of a cop-out which is gonna
lead to equality after what Fabi does
with 94 yeah I guess what were you
expecting in this position 92 is the
real question and I looked at this a
while and the big problem is not only
did rook the 8 not really help you get
your Bishop on c8 out but it blocked
your queen so for example if you go for
it with a move like d4 your Queens
actually in grief for example you only
have that square and then BAM things
didn't go homes things didn't go well so
I the best I'd come up with and I
practice this position a little bit with
our very own Yugi in peril Stein this
morning while watching the game and we
came up with this position and maybe
even later I might ask some of the
people the interviews we do what they
think of this position we I asked moku
Mian he thought this was just gonna be
like something that black could draw and
it's a little passive for black cause
it's passive and I I was playing Eugene
and I was able to at least give Eugene
grief let me put it that way
with basic plans like Bishop e2 followed
by at some point Bishop f3 anyway so
that to me was the story so Brooke may
be a bluff me and Maurice got an
argument like
a bluff and Maurice is like no he's done
computer analysis still move 90 you know
I get into it yeah studio ever Studio B
stuff's going on that's right it's um
anyways a very interesting draw two very
interesting draws and then of course we
got the rest day tomorrow and then
Monday we come back and so will always
weigh in with the two cents here if you
want a you know somebody else determined
give their two cents on a position like
this ask our YouTube channel yeah tell
us on YouTube we're definitely here I
will be reading all the YouTube chats
today so yeah welcome everybody such as
chess Kid 1 and Joshua Phillips we're
reading your comments so a big hi to you
guys Joshua Phillips watching from the
Ohio Valley so thank you to all of you
guys and everybody else that has been
chatting we will be taking a look
throughout the show and what you guys
have to say right and without any
further ado we do have a tournament here
so let's go ahead and take a look at the
standings for group a here at the winter
chess classic we do have a clear winner
in this section uni s ki Quesada Perez
is ahead with four points and chasing
right behind him is Geoffrey Zhang at
three and a half just below him st.
Louis University zone Darius Huertas is
right behind with three points and the
rest of the field is close enough that
we could see some big pushes for people
such as a secure and Krishna or Sam
seven to make a big move as this
tournament drags on there's still enough
rounds that anything interesting could
happen and in the B section we actually
have a much different story where we
have four people tied with three points
that is Lucas van forest Savin and
ricean Nicholas Theodore oh another slew
kid and Eugene peril Stein at three and
right below them in the chase we still
have a ton of people this is open to
just about anybody this field
JJ Olema Randy has two and a half and so
does Aaron hawk Obion Victor Michalowski
and old Benjamin so what are your
thoughts when you look at the B
standings in particular here is there
anything in particular that stands out
to you Jesse this is a real street fight
here anybody could win this and I think
Theodore was chasing a GM norm but he's
doing it in style almost every game he's
trying to sacrifice something so we're
gonna take a look at a lot of these
games today
a big fight with a Cobian and JJ mirandy
we take a look at that one yeah so wide
open and this is the field I aspire to
play him okay lay there all right and we
will take one more look in the chat Alex
Eastwood is asking the important
questions here which is where is the
rest of the Dutch opening videos I did
start a three part series on the Dutch
and we're still missing the third one I
can't remember if it got banned or if I
had a kid and then I stopped making
videos something did happen so that is a
great question where are the rest of the
Dutch videos I hope probably have made
it and that happens yeah perhaps I was
told no more videos for you you do three
parts on the Dutch they have to cancel
your show but do please keep asking the
important questions here in the YouTube
channel because I will be looking at the
chat all throughout the show today so
let's go now to the pairings for a round
six here in the a section if you look at
it we got Krishna and Sasha Kieran with
white against Darius we're her aunt Mel
Cumaean has white against Meera chenko
Jeffrey Zhong is taking on Ray Robson
Sam 7 versus Alexander mati Lev and our
game of the day that we will take a
brief look at here is Alexander Shimano
versus the leader uni f ski Quesada so
Shimano a local guy here at Webster with
two points but if he was able to manage
a win here it would be huge for the
tournament standings and uni F ski our
leader with four what is happening in
this game let's go ahead and take a look
at this point and Jessie could you take
us through this game and keep us up to
date with what is happening sure it's
been a really interesting game and this
is a very important game for casada
casal obviously leading the event and
he's done so really by playing very
solid chess and taking his chances when
he needed to
here he's in a fight for his life here
he's in a very difficult spot where
really all of Wight's pieces are better
than blacks it's not yet lost weight
hasn't had that doesn't have a
breakthrough yet but it is very
unpleasant for black and I thought what
I do is usually I start at the beginning
but I thought I just started in a
particular moment here
in a position here which looks pretty
familiar to anyone who's played these
kind of Carlsbad structures that's what
we call this pawn structure and one
thing I really admire about Shimano off
is he has had several games already in
this tournament where I have witnessed
him build up and attack his score isn't
that good cuz a lot of these attacks
have failed most notably we can't we
showed the game with Shimano versus
Geoffrey Zhang where he built up a
beautiful attacking game and then lost
it in time pressure and here's another
move I find very inspirational here look
what he does
he plays Bishop f4 and this is a this is
very inventive because first of all
we're telling black that he is going to
part with his dark square bishop if he
doesn't take and so black says okay I
will inflict what seems to be a pawn
weakness upon you but in return for this
what Shimano F is getting is a lot of
space with this pawn and there's this
pawns really doing two things it's gonna
threatening to harass the bishop with f5
and it's threatening this Knight jump
into here which is gonna look like what
I would call --is-- a pillsbury attack
structure very dangerous for black and
all of a sudden black went from this
position here where he looks absolutely
fine and this is one of those positions
where casada has been very good at
playing slow maneuvering chess and then
to this position where I don't know how
do you feel I suppose with the bishop on
f4 how do you feel about black trading
should he do it or should you just allow
white stake on d6 if he wants to well we
could ask us at a later if you regrets
but it's true what is true is that if
white just gets to take on d6 he will
also be better there
so what casada is saying is at least I'm
getting something for my troubles but
the way it works out why let's play this
through it does it doesn't work out so
Knight b6 and watch this
b3 no your Knights dominated very
unpleasant for the knight to be
like that Queen d6 the knight hops in
that's where he's going
and here's c5 black had a choice of
whether to play this move or not he's at
least trying to be active and Quezada
definitely does a nice strategy or is
basically saying I need to go to the
endgame really fast so here we go
Quezada says give me the endgame please
but it's not a pleasant endgame and you
can see how from this position we get
the game Quezada says I'm gonna trade
everything off and hope for the best
there we say no and very nice build-up
for white BAM
and so that is our current position with
King III does look very pleasant for
white doesn't it huge black squared
blockade and there's a lot of things for
black to worry about in particular you
can imagine this King marching to c5 at
some point these pawns on the Kings side
even though they're doubled they're
amazing
the pawn on f3 is keeping the knight out
and the other pawns are getting ready to
do all kinds of stuff with g5 whenever
white is ready to do so right you can
take its time yeah and I also just got
word that in the Joel Benjamin game
there is some action going on look take
a chance here to go jump over there and
see what's going on and while you search
for it let's see if there's any good
comments here people have opinions about
cats some people like them some people
don't
mister rethink does not like cats for
example very good to know
so been shaking legs oh is that what
we're witnessing here it looks like
there were some handshakes and I see
Joel Benjamin shaking his hands so I
believe I can ascertain the result of
this game real bummer for Joel I felt
like he was much better earlier on but
when you play this guy jumper you really
got it you got to watch your business
cuz he will come at you like a spider
monkey and that's what happened today
I'll just say you know I really like the
way Joel handled the opening he had this
position and got a pleasant position
nothing wrong with this position at all
something obviously went wrong and in
hindsight it's obvious that it has to do
with the Queen being separated from her
man and now f5 creatively bringing the
rook over let's see how this happened EF
rook over 94 snip Queen c7 alright why
just trying to get active counter play
here Bishop f4 boom boom now and I will
say this Benjamin you know oh man I
would say he he's had a couple games
it's just been you know really upsetting
yesterday he was completely winning
against big Mick but big Mick got his
way out and and now not only does he you
know he just loses this game and well
he's gonna be very upset as I should say
for the old guys out there
joel benjamin has won the u.s.
championship a number of times and
actually in around the year let's call
it 1979 1980 he was the next like
Geoffrey Zhang a little later than that
I would put that but you know early on
he was the kid that people were looking
for and you know now when you come here
I'm an old man too when we have our
senior moments and that's what joel
clearly had today and this is definitely
one of the like youngest fields to not
the team or younger guys yeah but it
does have to be hard for the US
hall-of-famer to come in here and try
compete against a lot of youth and
talent and yeah it is it is always tough
so maybe we'll have an interview
scheduled with mr. team or at some point
soon but I told then let's see how the
chat feels about cats wait wait no oh
wait wait wait I'm sorry we have it we
have a special thing a special thing
every time Timur wins we gotta show him
jumping out of the plane all right we
have video mister mister team were
jumping out of a plane so let's go ahead
and roll that
okay
[Music]
[Music]
Wow really amazing stuff yeah I love
that one
I like I've seen it a bunch of times
obviously I still I start like it it's
something that you can watch over and
over yeah and I believe you might even
be wearing that up there in the
tournament hall it looked like he had
some sort of stripes white and black
attire up there that's right yeah so
let's go ahead though now and take a
look at the other section and what our
pairings are for the B section in the B
section we got Aaron Paco bein taking on
Eugene Pearlstein Joel Benjamin wasn't
unfortunately upset by team or gray up
just right there Lucas van forest is
with the white pieces against picker
Victor nikolewski Robbie Kamlesh melee
is taking on Nicolas theodoro and zabun
and Rossi and has our game of the day
versus st. Louis University zone JJ all
Emer Andy who is in the hunt with the
two and a half points taking on one of
the leaders with three total points mr.
Andres Ian so without further ado let's
take a look at this big matchup and I
believe we do have a rather exciting
game here
well yeah a rather exciting game that
went to a draw up right away that just
ends as well I do want let's I do want
to show a little bit of this game though
because I admire the way JJ Morandi
played this even though I thought the
opening might have been a little suspect
so Andre ASEAN played Bishop d3 and as a
French player this is not really the
thing you should be most scared of but
still black did this and I don't
entirely believe in snatching the bishop
because it costs you a tempo to play
Knight d4 and then you're gonna give
white a tempo when you take because the
Queen comes up so white begins the game
up a lot of time here with 94
in this position I thought white was
simply better but I played these kinds
of things in the French as well and
there's a very simple philosophy that I
think JJ follows through on which is
eventually I want to first catch up on
development and then open the position
even if it means sacrificing upon I
don't care I want to open the position
for the two bishops and that's really
what he does and comes close to getting
a one position so that's the problem yet
on sacrifice yeah and then we're gonna
get active and this is a nasty this is a
nasty diagonal here so Brooke g1 Bishop
b4 snip and I definitely rather be black
here no Andre ASEAN holds on but look at
that boom there's some problems here if
there are some problems d5 takes takes
takes and that was that d5 move is an
attempt to bail out and black is
definitely a little bit better here but
it's going to be tough to actually win
in particular it would be nice if we
could keep one of our rooks on the board
but unfortunately I don't think we can
and that's well JJ come on JJ hey look
at how that night is dominated that
nights never gonna hurt you if you want
to move the bishop play Bishop b6 or
something
this is f3 oh come on JJ ok wait before
I criticize him too much I do see I
think he at least had an idea he said ok
you're gonna take I'm gonna take back
with the King and I'm gonna claim now
that I have my king is the better ok the
problem was that it's really kind of
hard now to do anything with say okay
yeah it's like and the split before that
pawns are a little bit of a problem so
now they quickly agree to a drill so I
guess in hindsight shame give the bishop
away don't give it away alright let's go
and look at some of our Group A games
just kind of run it down
to see what yes or anyone in particular
you'd like to start with let's start
with saucy he had a very brutal loss
yesterday against Evian he started off
with a beautiful position and things got
carried away and he lost in this game he
placed the advanced karo and this has
gotten a very bad rap for black in
recent years and black let's just say
some obvious stuff first of all white
can do a bunch of different things the
events car win principle is very simple
to understand you are playing a French
with your bishop out but it's gonna cost
you to Tempe to play c5 so you get your
Bishop out cost you two Tempe but the
clever thing the black can do is wait
I'm playing c5 because the moment you
play c5 you are opening up the position
and in particular you're gonna open up
this diagonal so let's go through this
Knight c8 a very kind of special move
just get out of the way and play Bishop
e7 and here's sauce II thought forever
and it's very difficult to make any
progress one simple plan that black has
is very annoying is some day I'm just
gonna play Bishop g4 get rid of my bad
Bishop and then go about my business
with c5 so to have like a French defense
with all the advantages and saucy
doesn't get much here and I like black
I'd rather be black let's put it that
way in this position but you can't have
a car player this is the kind of
position you sort of be hoping for yeah
as a French player to write this is the
dream this is the dream that you sign up
for when because you know as a French
player you're gonna suffer a lot so you
might as well have a dream about
something right so the game goes on it's
still gonna be a tale of who's the
better player and honestly it's a little
frightening now it's a little
frightening for black but I do believe
in in blacks position the rook on c8 is
nice and the bishop on a7 eyes there's
just some critical questions that sauce
is trying to answer I'm sure about what
is happening after say Bishop takes
and rook g3 mm-hmm if you if you don't
play Bishop takes and you play rook g3
immediately then you're gonna run it to
Knight a5 no it's not true even let it
sit wait mate oh boy we're not even
interested in the Queen yes so there's
two options there for him with Bishop e7
and rook g3 so well that looks scary I
don't I didn't want any part of that
what are you even gonna do after rook g3
time out yeah where do wait and what am
I missing Jonathan so what is the big
problem here then with like Knight g6 I
guess that's what you gotta do the sad
thing about it is I don't think that's
where you wanted your knight to be yeah
so how does how does your attack
continue though are you playing like
King h1 F where f5 trying to for that
sort of a thing or the point is I didn't
get checkmate it at some point I can put
my King on h7 I suppose game anyway yeah
hope for the best and you have to worry
about rook c4 a little bit mm-hmm for
example if h4 intending some weird stuff
like night g7 h5 rook c4 is going to be
unpleasant so that speaks to getting rid
of the knight right that speaks to
getting rid of the knight now and trying
for this and also Queen g4 is another
idea of what the same queen g4 maybe
Queen g5 yeah
so saw cease debating that will keep our
eye on that game Mero is doing one of
his another technical defenses the guy
is he loves he loves it just sit on
there what do you want from me son is he
you also see where he is in the
boardroom that is actually his favorite
seat by the way oh all right you can see
that the blinds there are closed but
sometimes you know there's a little bit
of Sun that creeps in and it gets in
your opponent's eyes so I didn't reveal
before the game but that is his favorite
chair in the whole boardroom that's all
one thing actually that's fun about this
is he's obviously suffering but he likes
to suffer and in this position y can go
into a pawn up rook and game but it
would be have some similarities with the
rook and game we saw today with Magnus
and favi where there was also dead
Magnus had damaged pawns I guess that
it's reversed because White's the one
with the damage but but the problem is
the damage pawns will make it harder to
realize the extra pawn and that's what
I'm sure Miro is counting on so I'm sure
he's imagining a variation may be like
this and rook c2 I'm there's white
doesn't have to do that but that's one
of the things he's just gonna claim that
this is well enough in the range of a
draw because the black rook is so active
that's probably true let's look at the
suffering of our Cuban friend Quezada Oh
No well you pull that up let's go ahead
and take one quick look here at our
YouTube chat yeah we do have Alexander
Cabrera Avila saying como lo escucha in
espanol I guess a lot of people have
relied on the Studio B commentary for
Spanish and other languages such as
Russian and maybe some others in the
future but unfortunately this one cannot
be watched in espanol very upsetting
alright now we got the game here now
yeah of course you've got the game and
it looks painful
yeah it looks painful as we predicted
the king is looking to penetrate and the
last move f5 is all about space and when
I introduced this position I was saying
you know it's gonna harass
bishop this time what it's really doing
is harassing the night because I want to
play King g4 and I don't want to get
checked and one simplistic way to
understand a position like this is to
say it's to just look at the pieces and
ask which pieces are better than which
of the opponent's pieces and here you
can it's the same story as it was
several moves ago where all of Wight's
pieces are better and they're that pawn
on d5 is weak then you can imagine if
the White King penetrates to the Queen
side forget about it right so a very
difficult game for casada which will
definitely impact our stance definitely
that would be a big shake-up if our
tournament leader not only couldn't win
but actually lost the game right Shimano
that would be be just huge and let's
take a look now at this other kid
critical game with Geoffrey Zhang
it looks like ray is easily holding this
end game that could be wrong but that is
just my first impression
Geoffrey started off really strong and
has been playing beautiful chess besides
the game with Shimano
I don't remember a game where he had
significant trouble and this game is
well not in trouble but I don't think
he's winning and so he's looking over
that Cassata game and saying you know I
hope Shimano this does to you what he
almost did to me Yeah right
that's like another one Samuel here said
young as we said earlier you know he
beats Aussie yesterday in a game that a
little bit lucky or whatever you want to
call it and he's been playing kind of
let's call it funky openings the entire
time this one started off a little bit
more conventional with this position
that's well known you know you play this
is an English some people caught a
reverse Sicilian and this is a well
known position for both sides and Mona
left gets this thing which looks okay
right and there we go here he's going
for it and I like this move age five a
lot five um as I said before you know
modal F is one of the greatest attacking
players of all time
and normally actually he's known to do
things that we're seeing Shimano in this
tournament actually do here he's going
for it yeah it looks like a lot of the
white pieces are on the queenside so I
guess he has his eyes on the white king
well and he also has his eyes on the
unopposed light squares here it's very
unpleasant for white and it's hard for
white to find squares for its pieces in
particular this Knight wants to move so
the bishop can do something and the
bishop wants to move so the rook can do
something so we're in a bit of a knot
over there and that there that knot is
the reason why modal if has the time I
think it's at least try to get away with
the move like h5 now h4 happens and how
really interesting what I wouldn't have
the guts to play this maybe I don't even
understand it no plays Bishop e7 all
right thinking of taking on h4 well
let's ask ourselves now would I take on
it I don't think we're ready to take on
h4 but what's the intention if it's not
to play that this would be so I'm gonna
say I don't know I don't get it
it's not is it's time to chill out and
put the bishop on f6 but you know that
Bishop is doing so much where it is for
example it's making it harder for this
bishop to say move to a-1 because of
this pawn right it's nice that we
control this we're honestly the dream
diagonal I think for that Bishop would
be somewhere over here so we're gonna
come back to this game and I'm just
gonna admit right away that there is
probably some deeper sense about vision
b7 that I don't get one obvious thing
actually is that h4 is laying the
groundwork for an invasion with the
night so at the very least Bishop e7 is
pre-empting that Knight maneuver and
maybe like you said with Bishop f6 that
that might be the way to meet Knight f3
is at least the calm approach is to play
Bishop on f6 and not SAC anything here
right and you know just contest the
other
Bischoff on the long term and and in the
problem actually let's just say you of
course you play night of three but the
problem is then my bishop gets to land
and it never it's not going away and the
other problem for why it's just
long-term at some point F for and then
the invasion on the light squares with
maybe the bishop but the queen would
also like to land down in there on the
light squares so actually let's take a
look at the big decision where he did it
here this is where Jeffrey arguably lost
his mind
that Jeffrey Samuel lost his mind and
played Bishop c6 there's of course
yeah I've seen people do this a lot in
the English in this kind of structure
the c6 pawn is you could call it week in
a better be week or you just gave up the
LightSquared Bishop for no reason right
and as we see that that Bishop let me do
something dogmatic that I'd love to do
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten he's got ten B squares that
he's controlling the night of course
will only ever control eight and because
it's unopposed you don't you can't touch
those squares so the bishop is really
touching both sides of the board we're
gonna call Bishop c6 a controversial
decision yeah yeah it's definitely one
of those you know it either works or it
doesn't kind of things and we are gonna
have to come back to this one because
I've been told well you can go ahead and
keep doing it we do have team or Gary
I've lined up for a big interview so the
man that jumped out of the plane
all right to see him here live and we'll
get to see what he's wearing today so
with that if you want to go ahead and
refresh his board to go yeah we'll have
team we're here in just a minute okay
yeah well actually I'm gonna look at
something else then when I get in here
I'm gonna ask him the questions that I
have we actually have some moves on
modal left game and it happened very
fast bishops see what happened instead
of Knight f3 and moto left said you know
what
I play Bishop e7 for a reason g5 very
double-edged and it's it's really hot
right now there's a big questions for
white as to what's going on intuitively
black has to believe that this weakening
is going to be okay
because his bishops controlled so many
squares there's a lot of questions
though here in particular like this
guy's always loose
that's obviously what Sam is saying that
that night is a problem but Sam needs a
good move now and the intuitive move
Knight of three is probably what he's
thinking about all right so we have team
were in the studio I'm gonna pull this
game up and we're gonna look at his game
I ask him a couple questions I guess and
the position I guess let's start it off
here with Knight c3 kind of an unusual
move Benjamins famous for unusual moves
and teamwork Welcome House Dundas now we
got a first ask a simple question is
that the same thing you wore when you
jumped out of the plane yeah nice
hahahahaha so Jonathan called it I was
like no he can't be worried the same so
you know whenever you win we play the
video so we just played the video so
that was cool yeah winds are not hard
I'm not easy to get in the Thor you have
to worry yeah we want you to win the
legs in the video what's your sense
about this Knight c3 move oh it's it's
very interesting and I'm sure what the
the amount of time that the players had
to you know prepare ahead of time so
this is something that I'm sure
Joel contemplated and then considered
and I looked at his repertoire so a lot
of times he'll play like like a more
positional so to speak version of
version of rule apes' yeah and here most
of the situations he played with 93
followed by d3 right is situations with
black's pawn on d5 so I figured instead
of necessarily getting into those main
two territories mm-hmm
I decided to play Bishop c5 which I
believe I briefly examined before so I
mean and maybe I did realize I might be
a little bit worse but you know it
surely is playable and certainly had its
upside
right well let's look I felt when I was
down I was up there looking at the game
I thought he thought he's a little bit
better here
well definitely he plays d4 puts
pressure but it's kind of a standard
edge sure Bishop on c5 maybe I look just
a little bit more ambitious mm-hmm so he
decides all right imma take this off and
you have a choice between the bishop and
the floor I would have loved to take
with a pawn keeping keeping more pieces
on the board right but somehow it felt
like Bishop f4 and E 5 is hard to
prevent and you have to kind of sit
there with that Bishop on d7 it's not so
pleasant right yeah because if I trade
those bishops after Bishop before I have
97 right I have that space for the night
to prevent that efile attack that's the
keyword space here are the space here
even though it simplifies the position
obviously reduces my chances to generate
any kind of decent attack and I would
say for here as white weight as surely
several different plans but the
challenge for him right is because
you've got that pawn on c6 he needs to
figure something to do with this Knight
right that's his challenge and it is
kind of hard let's let's say that's okay
he does this stuff that all looks kind
of normal you tell me if he does
something weird if so far this this yeah
there's like an alternative plan but
this makes so much sense right that if
you look at the position yeah very
classic yeah b3 set it all up except for
I think I'm doing okay yeah the defense
wise even though it looks kind of odd
but uh huh f6 is okay you know about
nimzowitsch is this incinerator la had
this whole thing where you got d6 + f6
sometimes at c6 and e6 against that e4
pawn it's like I'm in sinner I mean if
he goes forward he's gonna get
incinerator right and you and then you
kind of played incinerator tactics here
cuz you're gonna you have this idea of
doubling later on the e-file but also
you're you kind of have a sneaky idea
with rookie six
well as I played it out and yeah
yeah I guess one of those scenarios came
true huh yeah but it was definitely a
there's definitely several opportunities
for the rook to be active right from h6
so I mean yeah I did play up six but
really I want to play off five right
just the bishop is very strong in this
truth and yet it would be hard to pull
it off and already you know it's funny
like it seems like in short order
White's game is gonna fall apart but to
me looking at it I'd be very upset about
that night on a four I just don't know
what he's doing right well certainly but
I feel like Joel had a I think he set it
up all good I think for the next few
moves I think nothing nothing bad is
happening I think hey I'm doing all
right
but still I'm working towards the
quality I feel like right and maybe you
should avoid f3
nothing f3 is okay okay it's a
solidifies for the moment maybe I could
have tried Luca faith that's a little
bit more direct going for f5 but I find
it a little bit more committal as well
because then well I don't know
Ruka faith the Queen 85 Quincy eight and
then go for f5 and then the the tactics
I think work in my favor so maybe Ruka
faith maybe he needs to play g4 then I
don't know I mean let me tell you that I
that's dangerous just in itself get that
up 5min yeah I mean and what play to my
advantage in this game is certainly you
know how to meet the most most seemed
quite logical and fairly simple step
played pretty quick whereas Jala maybe
was looking for like the optimal plan
the very alread no idea and then maybe
also checking on some of the Connor
Connor Connor ideas that I'm a might may
have had throughout the game so he was
running out of time at this point and he
had about 15 minutes
well when I talked him later I'm gonna
I'm gonna scold him for that night
hahaha you know don't ever give me a
night like that again Joel come on look
at that thing
where is he going and like this one
rookie one it feels like he's trying to
use some kind of night c-5 trick to get
the night yeah well doesn't even know
what but this is a strong move this is a
strong move it made me think because now
it definitely takes the edge off d5 or
f5 right because his rook only one could
be become sometimes even vulnerable
right right and yes I could prepares
that Queen a5 and then an anticipation
of it I played Quincy 8 right so I would
have almost played rook afraid to play
f5 now but now actually when I play a5
also my e5 Knight would have been
hanging so I just move my Quinn away and
then prepare for the attack that I
played in the game so Quinn a5 I think
is this principled and can I just say
yeah I want him to bring his knight back
in I want him to play either Bishop c1
or Bishop a1 and then bring the dog home
yeah definitely I think that that could
work I think Bishop c1 and then I am NOT
playing a5 yet 92 over to d3 but I will
prepare a 5 yeah we should see one I
don't have the threat on g7 so I would
be playing Ruka faith so maybe then you
should be ready to play g4 because this
is the moment right where black you know
it's hard for black to do something
right now too but once he starts moving
the lady away from her man then that's
gonna be your signal that's gonna be
your signal for well maybe I got
something here right yeah I'm not trying
my my kind of semi-bluff yeah worked out
just because also Joel was a long time
so I figured it's time to just just play
you know I I wasn't sitting there
calculating I just I just saw one good
idea and I went for it
so when you say say my bluff do you mean
this move f5 no so Bishop e3 I think is
solid uh-huh because then okay so maybe
Quinn c3 here's is wise right especially
in the situation he was because then if
I put my Bishop over on the other
diagonal which Bishop h6 could be
actually quite interesting because it
also
hold my weak spot there on g7
potentially it could also be conducive
to some other other kinds of attacks
so yeah the 23 I think was would have
been smart for him to repeat as if
nothing else on Bishop h6 I can do I can
bring the dog yeah exactly exactly and
then you can at least trade the bishops
right then just simplify as it comes
down to you know they're just kind of
right playing playing on increment you
know so this one it's kind of like it's
it's like the belief that you can't do
anything when you play Knight c3 Knight
c3 just wasn't yeah 93 was part of the
major mistake I don't know like I think
legitimately why it was actually still
fine in the game right but just it just
doesn't feel right
lock in the Queen on a5 well right and
now there's all kinds of stuff that's
happening after a5 no because first your
rooks might touch your Bishop and then
he's there for life once your rooks
touch the bishop right now and then if
you it's you know he probably doesn't
want to let you play f4 he doesn't want
that right C's pretty much has to take
and then BAM also yeah you know I have
the option on now that would that I have
Bishop e6 idea
the in case like you plays do you wanna
play Bishop b6 with temple yes and then
look for other opportunities for attack
F II maybe d5 yeah get the e-file the
Queen's in her own little prison over
there she get back yeah
don't leave your man don't leave your
man so so here instead of 94 possibly g4
oh and then here you know this kind of
stuff obviously needs to be very well
calculated but as I said I saw one or
two good ideas and I just decided to go
for it just because of the dynamic right
I mean look all of my pieces are there
you know what were you gotta be waiting
all right so Bishop f4 rule cutter -
yeah also Queen d8 looks plausible
yeah Quinta bringing the Queen over here
yes in that case maybe a rook the one
Queen h4 all I know is your force count
is pretty good over there like rookie -
yeah it's just all the pieces I mean
something's got to happen that
and worst-case scenario you play Bishop
f4 UNH 3 lbs of the Queen winning on the
bottom yeah ok so you bring the lady
over the other yeah that this is a bad
marriage
this isn't gonna work out so yeah
already I mean it I get 94 it because
now it feels like we're punishing you
for letting my night back in yep but
unfortunately like your your ladies
coming in right now yeah yeah so here I
could have played Bishop b6 and then
picked up the pawn right but you know at
this point that's far in the game and in
the tournament I was getting impatient
okay let's just say couple things here
you have a nasty trick right with like
Knight f3 is it's right well most
importantly so the way he I mean I guess
he has to play Queen c7 because yeah
because of also yeah Luke h2 for by
Knight f3 those ideas I mean there's a
lot of tactics if you have 20 minutes to
sit and figure it out right but you know
certainly he had only a few minutes why
don't I show show this to the chest
yeah Queen e1 and then what would happen
here Oh Queen e1 well here that the cool
thing and that's a general
recommendation if you were trying to do
something crazy
uh-huh well if you have a perpetual
unless you feel like completely crushing
it right right but if you is some kind
of double edged attack well if you have
a perpetual then you only have so much
to lose right that's true yeah
do I have a perpetual well don't you
have Rick h2 and Queen h5 and King Jesus
Quinn g6 King h3 Queen age 6 Queen h4
then he can maybe if you can avoid it on
the perpetual end but here I haven't
sacrificed anything that I get you
should be able to find something here so
Bishop f4 is interesting sure when h5 is
interesting it's promising it's yeah
it's excellent I'm sure I'll keep my
Bishop on the diagonal I'm gonna tell
Joe later that if you get in a mess like
this you you bring your lady back home
because you know she's got competition
with this other lady come and try to
bring in the mate
this is not a nice thing yeah you know
don't leave your man at home alone
because this is what happens to you
Bishop f4 I don't know that's the
strongest continuation that's just
something I figured and what else can he
do so he can I know if you can let me
take on h2o
Queen h5 yeah yeah I mean it's hard to
believe you could let you take that
costume it yeah maybe
alright I'll what job did was actually
keeping him in the game so g3 nice moves
look at that nice tactic yeah and then
here he absolutely had to play a ruby g2
so now my my thought was queen g3 which
I as I said Irene h3 right yeah I was
just looking at it very very quick and
then here actually just 93 so my my dear
doesn't work at all because if when g3
the Muji - yeah and then I'm losing so
so Queen h3 doesn't work but here I can
certainly just bounce back with the
bishop to f4 yeah there is still keeping
my attacking chances and at this point
there's the tricky way to continue for
white and there's the probably the
proper way is to play Ruby G - yeah and
here interestingly is that g7 is just
okay maybe I have Queen of fate yeah
that's problem oh when a fade
yeah Queen of fate probably is the more
fighting option than the other look to
g1 so now he's starting you know
fighting back then I have Knight g6 so
then i keeping my I'm keeping my pieces
he's keeping his weaknesses but
certainly his his position is
coordinating better so did you know you
could play what rook g6 - yeah and
here's certainly room g6 as an option
and then after rook takes HG and I have
my queen h3 right
Alex dangerous dangerous idea yeah then
h2 is hanging so say a room g6 is pretty
strong I think so that's why I think oh
oh I see so yeah Ruby G to district g6
just before I was thinking about room do
you want so here I guess same and I
guess write the claim we're making is it
so he's taking probably too dangerous
if Quincy six and there's no this Queen
actually is still not going anywhere she
can't ever check she can't take this guy
she can't take that guy so I mean Queen
a jewelry is the obvious move maybe or
something else
yeah Queen h3 ROKAF to and get me to
that one night g4 is very strong I think
and I do for thing is winning yeah no
night of trick winner for oh excuse me
yeah my g4 o 94 very nice let's show
that that's a beast snip snip snip snap
yeah either rookie want to enough won or
queen and one yeah I'd like to use all
the pieces okay yeah so let's show the
the final tactic here very nice I'm
assuming Joel was a hectic time pressure
here yeah he had to just about three
four minutes on the clock
so Bishop g3 and the trick is it a nice
I don't know what he thought I was gonna
do so 9 g3 he might have thought Queen
h3 yeah and then I'm gonna try some kind
of like crazy further sacrifice with
some kind of Perpetual maybe or
something
uh-huh dad so the obviously that's the
idea you can in and that's easy to miss
it's kind of subtle right yeah yeah yeah
and then they're just well I'll tell you
what it doesn't look that set off right
now exactly that yeah yes it's tough to
even yeah where he's I mean there's
there's some there's some geometric
tricks but but they're just like Bishop
e5 most importantly D oh sorry
so night-night age sorry 9h 5 or 9 h 5
yeah Luke age 5 then this should be 5
yeah
so here there's like looks like there's
some choices may bring the other route
over but then there's some checks right
so be here just D D and the same thing
you know alright know what a beautiful
game thanks for showing it to us and one
thing I'll say the chess fans is team
were didn't start off that strong missed
the first game yeah but now is in the
tournament this because this tournament
there's only a plus one is the higher
got so you have a chance I should worse
is very surprising the sporting price
when I looked I was like what's going on
here
yeah like is that the pairings for the
previous round then I see that I'm
playing Joel right right right
like oh man the most people for the
players have is three points yeah would
have been actually of course we've been
nicer to to have a better start but
hopefully uh you know I'll get some more
nice games especially with white you
know yeah you know it's a little bit
tough to build up so twice that I build
up like a very impressive looking game
and then also I find out I'm playing
playing a grandmaster who doesn't want
to lose yeah just all right [ __ ] thank
you so much all right we'll take a break
we'll be right back
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chess
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenged them
to a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with chess twenty-four Premium
Membership
[Music]
all right and welcome back to st. Louis
where we still have a nice round you're
going in the winter chess classic as
always I want to thank everybody that
has been active in the YouTube chat
where why are men in my shoes has been
very active today with lots and lots of
comments I'm just getting back to the
desk I will keep an eye on all of your
fantastic amazing comments here so
please keep them coming if you have
anything good to say we will check it
out here on the show but Jessie I'm
wondering what is happening in that case
sided game and we remember that that was
the one where Shimano
was looking pretty good there with the
more active pieces so take me through
what's happened and what was missed here
all right you know one thing when we
think about chess talent and chess
brilliant as we often think about
brilliant attacks and that kind of thing
but when you really are playing at a
high level what you're gonna have to
learn to do is learn you're gonna have
to learn how to suffer and what Cassatt
is doing here is giving us a clinic in
how to suffer and I think we will go
back to our position that we right
around here we stopped last time is
where we stopped right and it's a real
dilemma to figure out how to help black
out so watch what he does
Bishop d7 and white says I'll first hit
you here Knight a six but I do not
really want the trade I don't want to
let you trade anything off so f6 happens
I think that's a strong move the knight
comes D 3 Bishop goes back so the bishop
is aiming to go to e2 so if the knight
on d3 is actually aim for h5 Knight f4
to h5 exactly right and that's why
Bishop ea8 happens to guard against
Knight h5 and check it out on Knight f4
we have Knight c7 and let's just think
that you six squared let's think about
all these things that casada is covering
for a moment the night
this one is covering b5 and b6 the
bishop is covering h5 so when we look at
the position it's hard to imagine white
ever getting anything in that doesn't
involve those square
right notice also that the nights are
really well aligned to protect the d5
pawn and if the bishop needs to at any
point it can go to f7 Scioscia Manav has
a very strong edge but it's gonna be a
real challenge for him to find a plan
here we're about to hit move 40 actually
I think we have a couple moves has been
played let's put those on the board
Bishop e2 and Bishop f7 not surprising
we've hit move 40 okay so yeah we'll
have a time for a big think and we'll be
able to see if he's actually able to
find a way to break through here right
and I think you know one thing that's a
challenge for Shimano
is he's so good at getting these
attacking positions but often times you
know this is when you play at the
highest level you got to knock somebody
out from here and this takes a lot of
not only creativity but grit cuz you're
gonna be you're gonna be tired and it's
gonna be rough yesterday I thought he
had a very nice position against Rea
ropes in it I felt he gave to draw a
little too easy I thought he gave the
draw too easy so this is getting to this
position as his strength and now is the
challenge to convert and this isn't an
easy position to figure out what white
should do and in fact it might if he
doesn't come up with an idea a ASAP it's
just gonna be a draw yeah and one thing
I know white would love to achieve here
don't know how to do it but if you could
trade the life squared bishops for
example that would sort of open up a lot
more squares potentially for the white
knights to hop into don't see a direct
way to actually achieve such a plan but
well it has a dream I don't know how
much it would help but you could
consider for example to move like Bishop
b5 and try to tell black that he's close
to Zook Swan but you know it's a long
road it's a long road there let's look
at mural he's achieved what he's been
dreaming of achieving which is a pawn
down rook endgame okay interesting you
know Miro is a very solid player in this
German he's just I think going after a
strategy of playing ultra solid he only
lost round 1 and that from against modal
F in a position that he probably could
have held honestly a position kind of
similar to this
though I guess that one let's say it was
a little bit hard to hold here I think
in principle he's right he should hold
this relatively easily but my friend
will come in he's gonna make him suffer
this is the kind of thing honestly I
think the World Championship is going to
be decided on cam like Magnus or Fabi
press in a position like this and we've
already seen that in the first two games
now with rook end games with up a pawn
with some pushing and so far we've seen
that it's been a draw both times so far
we saw this yeah it's obviously a very
difficult one to convert I think it's I
think one thing that I wish a coach had
told me at an early age though in all
seriousness was you get a position like
this tell yourself that you are gonna go
the entire distance just prepare
yourself mentally to say I don't care if
it's technically a draw I'm gonna push
and push and push and usually the game
will be a draw but often I will find
some way to crack this guy and I'll have
the will to do it
yeah and most people just don't have
that will it's rare it's very hard
especially on the amateur level I mean
you don't sit here and play you want to
go eat in the Thai place yes in here
dwelling on it but that is basically
when it gets to the top and every single
half point gets harder and harder to
achieve you see people just suffering
and grinding and I feel like someone
like Magnus and Fabi they're both
grinders they sit there for a long time
and they're both willing to do it and
you do see it and pay off when they get
a half point here a half point there
don't get it every time but I think both
of them they have what it takes to sit
there and grind to grind away and let's
look at some more suffering here my
friend Yugi and Beryl Stein from a
position I thought he was totally fine
got himself in a bit of a mess here and
this night on 88 he is the pitcher
picture of suffering that's not a good
night and cocoa peon has very simple
plans to break through I would guess now
is the simple thing is to say well let's
try to trade off your good Bishop and
and see if the King running in is a
winning endgame and in a lot of ways
what it's starting to look like is a
king upon endgame right a kingdom far in
game
we're White has more just more
flexibility because at any point he can
bring the night around and he's the one
who gets to decide when the night is go
back into the good yeah that's very true
so we'll check in on that one
Eugene definitely had some struggles
let's do my old man my favorite old man
Victor playing the young champion that
forced his plate already a number of
good games and lost yesterday but it's
still one of the people with three
points Jonathan what's your first take
on this position so first of all I do
see that night on a three not exactly
sure where it's going so I just see kind
of a better minor piece potentially for
white here not sure if that Knight is
getting trapped somehow if we can guard
to be one square we could play we're up
to a two such as do it though you can't
bring the bishop around quite yet well
one thing I will point out in big mix
favor is that he's up upon that's good
and Vic Mick is beautiful with positions
like this making people suffer and if
he's gonna win it's gonna have to be
some kind of thing like a rook g7 where
white can't get back you know but it is
hard to see how that actually would work
so big mix trying to figure it out big
Mick one of his problems is time
pressure and here it is we can see he's
got one minute left I think he just made
a move and in fact he's made two moves
let's look at what happened he went for
a five rook d2 and it really is a bummer
with the night so the knight right so if
you trade the rooks if you trade the
roost you probably will lose that chair
yeah so rookie 7 and he's almost luckily
these days you get 30 seconds to move
you still might be able to get that and
it is worth pointing out that these
clocks are not always accurate because
there's a slight delay between the dgt
and what right is actually happening but
it's a pretty close to accurate this
actually it's starting to look a little
scary for big Mick I mean even a white
can start thinking about things like
check to the miserable King and then
King D - yes how bad can that be the
King will eventually get to the v2
square maybe I'll make a slight addendum
to that if rook D - let's say King g7 I
don't know exactly where to go but if
you go King D - I think I have a trick I
could take and then 91 take C 3 so
that's a trick that White has to watch
out for but in general here White's got
some time and he's been suffering for
most of this game but he might be able
to find a way to really mess with our
friend big Mick here very true
route d6 King g7 on the board let's see
what happened king d2 was played uh-oh
oh my god wait no no no no see sometimes
it plays my own moves for me but that is
not actually what happened white is
thinking about the famous king d2 and
big Mick will have a minute and 16
seconds after he plays it to figure out
what to do several moves are possible
here and big Mick is basically counting
on the pressure of the rook to keep this
King away from my knight and if big Mick
gets a move it's obvious he's gonna play
Knight b1 alright to get out of there in
fact it mighty why does to be careful I
mean this is like indeed of course if
you don't trap the night well he's gonna
come back in he's an angry piece
in fact one basic positional threat is
takes takes Knight c2 and then an
octopus here on e3 okay white did take
rookie 5 and my feeling is is that white
should hold this but it's it's getting a
little tricky for example King D -
Knight be one king C - and I get to snip
this guy that's unfortunate
yeah and we just say we you're a young
guy and you want to take big Mick down
in the endgame well that's gonna be
that's gonna be with some work in there
for you friend because big Mick one he's
heard a lot of people he's hurt me hurt
me several things personal so uh
theodoro who is chasing the GM title got
a drought with kevlars villi alright
looks like a drop it looks like a draw
right and then of course jayjay morandi
got the dress of several early draws so
in Group E we're looking at big mix game
and we're looking at Eugene's game the
bigs - you know big mix game is more of
a technical suffering and Eugene's is
more like a long term stomachache
because it's just not going away y can
do it so many things and you know what
we're not going to get into now but you
can well imagine it's just the kind of
zoom swans that can develop and Eugene
actually played a very committal move
let's check it out he must be saying
that he has some kind of fortress now
with g6 I'm not sure I believe it but
it's a thought and maybe actually his
idea also to play f5 if allowed well one
thing right I think he maybe is rightly
concerned about is if he didn't play in
g6 then Bishop g4 was really gonna
demand the exchange of his good Bishop
but just really is only good piece
because imagine if you go Bishop ei then
my bishop goes to start talking to your
knight mm-hmm
right and I don't think that's gonna win
I think the real question is then is it
a win if you trade these bishops it
looks it looks like it right because we
have the zukes wrong possibilities and
we're gonna do things like King f5 and
wiggle we're gonna wiggle our way in
there so g6 might be an act of simple
desperation it it looks bad for example
well this is it's okay so for example
here's a way that here's just a
variation where black survives takes
kake's snip snip snip snip and I yeah I
think he survives no because of the
activity right that there might be more
to that than I just show but that's just
an example and if Bishop g4 I suppose
were then assuming that f5 is gonna
that's what I was wondering if he was
banking on here which has its own drama
because now we're gonna get an outside
passport but the idea I guess is to say
well white at least your Bishop isn't
gonna trade mine and it's not gonna
really penetrate because at least blacks
hoping they should can't do anything
nice with vision maybe black can hope
for some activity to at some point maybe
he'll get a passer but all honesty
doesn't look quite good for white in
this position there's got to be some way
here to grab this is definitely a big
well so let's Cersei's something obvious
g6 is a committal move which is maybe a
last-ditch attempt and probably
corrected saying that we have to see any
trouble so I don't know maybe put it
this way I don't know which plan you're
gonna choose white you have a lot of
different plans but I know that I have
to stop Bishop g4 right here's another
nice variation if takes takes Bishop g4
then I think I can take right now
because there's no way how do you walk
in right into it so there are some I
would believe if I was white just
looking at it that I would have
something very promising here yeah
there's some win there's a win here
that's right where is it where is it
yeah and I'm glad the players have to
find it not us I know I think it back if
I would love to be playing this
tournament I like commentary but you
know I I would love to be in there and
having to solve this would be the kind
of problem you want to solve you don't
want to be in Eugene screws having to
solve the g6 is very pleasant to have
the whites problem here alright alright
let's take a look well you do that let's
try to get a little bit more activity
here in our YouTube chat though I do
like why are men in my shoes one of our
most
active commenters today who said I like
both the commentators yes I would like
this time to encourage some other people
feel free to at this point press one in
the chat if you think we're good
commentators and two if you think we are
the best commentators of all time please
do not know for three
but yes please try to be a little bit
more active in the chat because we will
read it you write it we read it all
right what game has your eye are you
looking back at the case not a game well
as a famous gisado game the issue that's
going on here is that on night C 8
okay so Bishop to b5 what's played
bright white need tonight only one here
that was gonna happen there yeah and
it's not so easy to figure out what's
with what White's intention is
especially if the knight can just bounce
back and forth so yeah shimano if needs
an idea that's what he needs
I don't know there there are several
ways for example one way to mess with
them is to play 92 to G 3 and then H 5
yes you do have two nights so you wanted
me to go to h5 there's gonna be ways to
meet that but that's just at least an
idea right so let's expect some
long-term brief there let's go ahead is
he watching this check all right yeah
but yeah I do want to agree with mr. our
tech Manu peon who says no best is
fiddler
very true fiddler is an excellent
commentator uh yes lots of ones and twos
and a three so thank you guys for
joining well you know we're looking at
Mero suffering yeah Oh
professional suffering the game that we
really need to check in on and I'm sorry
I'm sorry viewers I've been neglecting
this game it's been very interesting for
a long time let's go to where the big
decision was long ago which was we had
Knight h5 King g8 and this is where we
were talking about the decision between
Bishop e7 and rook g3 right what did he
come up with so in fact he played rook
g3
Knight g6 and one reason one of the many
reasons that Krishna is a better player
than me is I would have had a little bit
of hesitation after I started seeing
things like rook c4 it would have just
scared me off of this problem Bishop e7
felt safe but maybe it was told me if
I'd be three or something well he plays
Queen d3 and let's take a look at this
for a moment imagine rook c4 the
intention I believe is the snip just
take it all right and look at this
terrible thing your king can't move your
King can't move and then when you do
this Knight of six its mate well it's
not me good be your queen but this
bishop is fulfilling a very pivotal role
here yeah so queen d3 looks very nice
and it's it's definitely still scary
because there's a bunch of things black
can do in the game black just said okay
no I own I own the light squares and now
b3 so this is close to what I was
suggesting I was saying we have to keep
the rook out rook h7 it's not pretty
b5 a5 okay keeping an ear down that b3
pawn to move with the move b5 hoping to
take on a4 get the b3 pawn to move later
okay for sure this didn't happen this is
some look at this thing he's trying to
do here I'm not sure I buy it
he's trying to say I'm getting out of
the way there and my rook is like
permanently bad so this is starting to
look good for Krishna and I think this
work if I still believe in blacks
position here but this is where black
need to find a better idea of trying to
unravel and maybe even you know to think
about King h7 here that's the only way
your pieces are ever gonna fully make
sense right you're pinning your knight
and everything I get it but with this
move rook h7
well I don't like it I don't like it's
bad is that's the improvement right me
this that's Ian to probably be waiting
for why do and look at this nastiness
look at this you could beYOU could play
that for here but look what he did
BAM oh boy no it's not about these we're
not interested in I never want to touch
your rook ever
that's a boom have you seen a worse it's
hard to find this rook actually now it
can dream about playing h5 and rook h6
so at least has a dream but
unfortunately there's some basic
questions like 97 this is a nice square
to hold anyway black is a guess obliged
to do what he did no trade f33 let's
talk about that move for a second a
lesser man like myself would have wanted
to play something like f4 I suppose
maybe he didn't put it on f4 because in
the line where you play h5 rook age 6
then your Bishop doesn't take that rook
and no that's a valuable point yeah so
also is he worried F for Queen a5 is
that a worry it could be it's also
question though like when you see this
move f3 it's like well what's the
long-term plan and my sense is is that
we don't mind necessarily trading Queens
we just want to make sure this rook
never moves mm-hmm right so maybe like
if I could get that kind of action or
pawn all the way to h5 this is the
enumerate the entombment variation we're
not necessarily playing for mate we're
playing for the entombment of the roof
let's see how how it goes for so h5
trying to get out h4 no you're not
getting out
Brooke c6 g4 oh very very nice notice
that he doesn't care that the rook has
an optical out it's not really an out
and if you play Hg I'm just complete F G
with a temple on your queen and I'm
gonna play h5 in the the full entombment
would have happened to my beautiful
Bishop e7 King G - oh very nice very
nice play very patient I love it this is
actually one of my eye I think this
could go and you could put this in a
book this is a very nice strategical
lock on black Bishop d8 c3 now that's a
tricky move because you're allowing
black to take so let's just see if we
were ignorant and took this thing what
what a terrible thing would happen to
black here
like maybe that's your best shot here is
black yeah right it's not a media it's
not immediate they just plain before and
just saying whatever lockdown maybe but
why don't we have we didn't really have
to play c3 right unless there's
something obvious we're missing here I
guess I don't understand c3 this is why
I like the commentary on people who's
games are better than mine cuz they do
theft and I have to really ask like what
cuz c3 is intense and then I saw a
there's some problem with Bishop a5
taking you're a pond give me it's
probably really obvious doing it at all
took your pond
yeah I don't know what it is where was
his bishops back here is the bishop like
okay so I'm gonna count that to my own
ignorance I have no idea in the game
black played Queen e8 why it said f4 Wow
yeah
thanks to everybody in the chat lots of
love in the chat today it's weird I
haven't heard a lot of people saying bad
things about us I know there's trolls
out there you guys must be out there
it's been a very clean yes this is
something amazing going on Jonathan this
is like well this is next-level stuff so
maybe the idea was zero
Bishop a5 III really don't get it but
maybe this is truly the intention where
it doesn't look intuitive because of
this guy and then what it what is your
intention is it yes the thing a5
I think okay let's just see if this is
actually real because takes rook takes
right wing takes
oh boy take it all back take my pieces
we're missing we're missing some key
idea here and I don't know what it is
because f4 happens and then the obvious
question would be like hey buddy what if
I take your pawn so there is a person in
chat asking what about c4 after Bishop
takes a five thank you for the question
zucchini man c4 and let's say snip let's
just assume cinetic
all right let's assume snip we're doing
here
my particular night and my bishop
there's the zucchini man might have some
point you know you could say Queenie for
maybe there's a lot of there's still
more questions though like maybe this is
take feedback yeah just a little bit
before so when we played the c4 mm-hmm
perhaps even right here because I wonder
if there's all this things are
overworked here
I wonder can't we just take the bishop
yeah and then your Knights gonna be
hanging if you take me back yeah I
assume zucchini had some idea with take
not quite saying it'd be fun I don't
know maybe there's not maybe you
blundered upon you know I visit I say
usually when they play a really good
move I have an idea of what they're
doing there here we have several moves I
don't get it okay I just gonna be honest
you guys I don't get c3 are we gonna be
mega impressed or what happens so f4 as
you pointed out ages ago is
controversial because the rook is
allowed to go to age six know there's
multiple questions about a before you're
also losing the g4 pawn is that what
you're what Rick h6 is the problem right
but there's some also problem here I
don't understand well that's a very just
well let's try it one more time here
actually so f5 alright
and if you take maybe this is your
problem now your Bishop is hanging here
hmm
I assume that's oh it's hanging if you
play Queenie six right and if you play
rookie six I can think about both rook
f5 and Knight f4 right okay so even that
I'm gonna say is really complicated
because rookie six if Knight of force is
queen c6 hello I'm not even sure that
you're even better anymore
in such a line sort of losing everything
so check it out rook h6f another thing
that really where black could start
believing in myself is at least now look
at his these rooks are going to start
being connected now one thing is often
the cases you got some guy in entombment
and you still have to bust the castle
open you got a big razzle open in order
to break through so let's see how this
goes takes takes all so I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna say for sure saucy was in
big-time pressure King h7 snip and snip
and now no one knows who's better in the
boy no one knows who's better so a lot
of suspicious-looking things in there
things definitely I didn't understand
but also I'm sure you know the computer
probably wouldn't like it but this is
what happens when you play at a high
level and you've been playing for a long
time already and your time is clicking
down and saucy does if he has one
weakness it might be time pressure here
and so let's just look this was the
beginning position where I'm gonna say I
like white a lot and he expended a lot
of of time to reach this beautiful thing
and things got crazy though
and now the rook got out there he is
he's out and let's just play one more
move will go to another game and say
let's just play one more move there's
more than one check but I don't know
they just take the rook for second with
the rope they're both both look I'm sure
he's thinking about both now right okay
so that's where we are so this was not
played actually yeah this is where it
takes was play I'm sure Queen takes is
playable it will we just on the surface
though we're gonna have to say
we'd rather be black right I feel like
whatever white had it's it's kind of
overwhelmed yeah
sassy said it's time to go on a journey
and that's never a good sign
yeah whatever wait had it's over loads
of pleasant moves here for black you
know rook g-force some kind of Queen
move thing it didn't go well
upon singing - it's a bummer about you
know playing really beautiful creative
chess is that you know you you find your
way to some beautiful position but you
spent so much time and energy getting
there that you can't convert and
speaking of that let's see how Shimano F
is doing because he has a similar
problem against you neski and yeah he's
been tanking ever since this night c8 to
see it correctly if he has some kind of
breakthrough plant here it doesn't it
looks like probably not but you know
he's gonna try looks like we're gonna be
here well they're gonna be here I would
stay you know you guys want to extend
the show y'all stick around let's go and
look at Eugene and see what happened why
changed his tune a little bit let's look
at g6
so why changed his tune it said Bishop
f1 one beautiful thing about White's
position is he can sit this is actually
a variable note this is a very Russian
old-school thing to do is they you know
you make moves that look like they might
threaten something and really what
you're doing is you're giving your
opponents some time to be afraid but
yeah give them some time to be afraid
and also giving yourself time to think
about all the different plans
looks like Eugene has a lot less time to
now do you well do you see any ideas
here that Haram is thinking about yeah I
was going to do does I guess the
question is does he have some dream here
it looks like he's dreaming but I'm not
sure like yet maybe he had some dream
about Bishop c2 f5 in any case he said
you know what I'm just gonna cruise back
to Bishop f3 and this is the kind of
moving around that I think is is good
practice just move around and maybe if
you're winning it's not going away
I don't know if he's winning but it's
more like we're just gonna make him
suffer for a little bit and he might
crack I don't see a way through but I I
wouldn't be surprised if there is you
know yeah I wouldn't surprise me at all
so that's the suffering there eugene
good luck that's a key game for the
standings of course
Eugene even though he's only at +1 like
we're at saying with teamwork that
section is so wide open that a +1 you're
no you're leading the tournament okay I
got a look at big mix game yes please
alright so let's back up where we had it
we are looking at rookie 5 king f2 and
the thing about King f2 is now going the
other direction white is definitively
saying I give up on corralling your
knight yeah it's alright so now he goes
loose bishops erupted e7 first snip the
pawn snip and a5 now let's think about
this for a moment this looks right so
the reason is is that if you play rook
a7 big Mick is going to take any 3-point
no this was certainly an option you know
but the problem is the night in the rook
will actually coordinate well to create
an attack of their own that's that's
part of the drama for example on King f3
you could play rook e3 or 93 King e2
same thing so there's no pleasant way
out of it so white decides to play a 5
and you know when you're black and
you're trying to win against a strong
player a lot of times you get some messy
position like this where you are up a
pawn but white definitely has
compensation the bishop is now very it's
both both minor pieces are strong but
the the bishop and the rook are working
well together and basically black needs
to find a way to give white grief before
the a7 pawn drops an ace five palm
starts marching
I think big mix should be able to find a
way to do it probably starting with
ninety four but there's probably Rookie
7 is also a totally fine candidate move
right yeah so I like big mix chances
there and this h4 pawn is menacing not
only to later advance but you know the
control this square is going to be nice
and a lot of variations I love the video
so we got so we got some squirming going
on here we got some squirming going on
in both groups and like I said you know
people a lot of times people get
offended by draws and those are the
commentators I don't like me and Maurice
are gonna have another fist fight about
that anytime soon and because you know
he's really upset when they drop but it
takes a lot of skill to try to hold
positions like this and even though
Magnus and Fabi sometimes make it look
easy it is not hard and it takes a lot
of spiritual and physical and mental
energy to hold it together in a six hour
of play yeah a few people have these
virtues right that's right let's check
in with with saw see this would be a big
loss of course and dar was really just
mulling over his beautiful options here
I learned a nice word actually I'm gonna
ask van forest about it apparently in
Dutch you know there's a phrase you say
it's a luxury choice well okay choice
right so black has it at least it seems
like several good moves that seem like
they'd be good the problem is let's say
it this way the problem for white is or
for black excuse me
is that white does have a space
advantage in the sense that it's hard
for the black queen in particular to
jump out and that could be one argument
for example for playing your move you
will your instinct with queen g6
mm-hm totally fine move the question
there though it's similar is like well
then how are you gonna get the rook in
right after but I'm queen g6 might have
also been quite good I guess the problem
is once the King moves I don't know
which Square h2 or h1 like yes you can't
was to take one of your pawns my bishops
hanging and you have two pawns hanging
right my intention was to take one
probably the h1 right and then you got
to worry about rook g1 and that kind of
thing and maybe I should have yeah okay
anyway so that's that's where we're at
and you know it's a it's easy for me to
sit here and say black should have
something here because I don't have to
find it but it does look like you know
there should be something here for black
Bishop h4 there's got to be at least a
little something-something it feels good
because even on Rick h1 I can play rook
g4 it's not like my bishops getting
kicked out you know okay so that looks
very pleasant
Sassy's having a rough time you lost
yesterday does two Savion from a very
nice position time pressure here time
pressure again maybe oh you know that's
in those weird decisions like I don't
want to ask that's too painful my friend
Mel chromium he is still making Miro
suffer here's a funny thing so I'm
hanging out he's it stay in the same
place I am right we're hanging out which
for those that don't know we have these
chess houses just read right so if you
play in one of our tournaments here is
this one of these gems Iams playing in
these big tournaments right you actually
get to stay right down the street
can you walk right one building over and
you get to play in the Chess Club
so you know a lot of times when people
ask me where I'm from I say I'm from the
80s because that's you know when I
came up and so I'm listening to these
80s songs Anna runs over there and we're
just hanging out and for whatever reason
we get songs by the Smiths coming on
like old Smith songs from like beautiful
old Smith songs and the guy knows all
the lyrics and it's really weird when
you think about because the Smiths songs
like when you listen to it it's like
you're gonna catch some of the lyrics
but to know all of the lyrics it's like
wow I was really taken aback I was like
more than one song he could do this and
he told me the story where LaVon turned
him on to the Smiths oh really
and I'm like listen Smith yeah then we
went to the Cure he knew the lyrics the
Cure song and then once you get stuck in
the eighties you just can't stop I think
here's here's the thing not obviously
it's just a beautiful band but he told
me this other thing that like Armenians
don't like to smile you know you start
listening to enough Smith songs and cure
songs oh yeah you're not going to be
smiling all the time you know that's
what it is yeah they're listen to so
much emo music that the whole country's
come down into a national pain mode yeah
all right everybody I think we're gonna
wrap it up there on that beautiful note
go ahead and follow the games on us
chess champs calm and a lot of games
going on like I said I would stay
forever
Bishop h4 by the way let's let's do a
quick recap yeah how much we need to
stay Bishop h4 was just played and black
is gonna have the long-term threat of
the h-bomb but more importantly mating
potential with moves like rook g3 very
hard to deal with and maybe a move like
Queen e4 enough to try to pin and win
you're not actually gonna win but you
gonna slow him down
alright alright let's take a look
Miro is continuing to suffer I believe
that he should hold that though uni s
key the big game he's done he's done an
interesting thing here this actually was
we actually we had to pause here for a
second 97 and Shimano says you know what
I'm gonna put a I'm gonna
change the structure of the position
right now and casada is thinking about
he's got to take tonight because the
night on a7 is hanging and he's thinking
about which night to recapture on and
also maybe just the question like what
is it that whites intending here well
well yeah what else was wait to do it's
he's gonna try to win I guess he's gonna
try to shake it up somehow
let's just say something obvious when
you take no you're gonna have to take
back with the pawn either now or the
next move let's just put it here for
just just to show the problem b6 could
be played I'm sure other moves are
possible and then why'd all of a sudden
has to worry about Bishop eh don't take
my partner please don't take my pawn bro
so I think the intention must be Bishop
b5 and then if you take no you don't
have to take well black doesn't have to
take the thing well take it but let's
just let's just do this for kicks I'm
not sure at all about this position
especially because it's now white who is
in Zeus one but one intention could be
to say well fish be 896 unfortunately
though no right nowyour there's no
there's no move for white here this is
one of well take it back and one funny
wait wait you could play h5 yeah I'm
also looking at one one other funny line
so if you go back just one move here
wait wait it's five or what's gonna
happen I'm gonna assume Bishop p8 96 I
don't know how to evaluate that but it
looks like maybe white could you know
have some fancy tricks I'm not even sure
about that though mm-hmm you were gonna
ask a question I'm sorry I still a funny
thing just based sort of on the same
we're trying to create a situation if
you yeah if you go all the way through
and we took on b5 twice uh-huh with the
bishop the bishop on here I'm trying to
get some funny position where I can even
play a move like Knight h5 where if you
know say that your bishops on ei like
like there should be eight nine eight
my idea if my funny idea which doesn't
have to happen at all that say like this
yep
is it if you ever take my night and I
take back why does the one that has the
reserved tempo so I'm waiting I'm gonna
play move I have a little bit for if I
need it but otherwise I'm just
straight-up taking no you're a genius
yeah unless I'm not even breaking
through there no I think this is and you
know what it's important that you have
this f4 move in reserve because what
black boy the way could go down as you
go like this black puts you in zoom so I
can say no you're in takes one that
won't extra tempo I got all those double
puns props for Jonathan yeah props for
Jonathan let's let's go get that idea
again that was pretty cool um yeah so
black is not okay now forced to take it
but it's it's important just to
understand like what the idea might be
because it's honestly you know not
immediately obvious it wasn't
immediately obvious to me now
like you said we could just play a move
like b6 right definitely don't want to
but the drama could be snip-snip
and write some kind of knight h5 when we
want it but I love this variation here
b6 night h5 bro yeah yeah if only you
were forced to take me well I'm sorry
but let's let's take a look so Bishop eh
snip-snip
the bummer for white is the night the
night wants to win another one of those
pawns but it's not that easy to do it
you also worry about this bishop coming
to e2
yeah but you know what like me but
actually right away we go boom let's say
you start well you don't really want to
harass now is is yeah this is going for
ste forward this is no danger yeah
that's real danger okay so let's let's
pit let's look at this for a second so
Knight a b5 happened and yeah we're
gonna look so I'll tell you what before
I leave we're gonna come back to that
game just to check it out sure let's
just do one last one
Lord Rama Cobian is gonna dance a little
with a knight and one bummer is he can
always go back to
it's so unfortunate so you know and your
white here what you're gonna try to do
is create some situation where the
knight can come back in a way that
forces black you know to do the dance
and this knight can start kind of coming
back but he's honestly not gonna be
doing go one step closer to being back
right he has to keep pace with the other
night right so it's not so easy
so there's true suffering and Victor
let's see how Victor's doing 85 checked
to the miserable King King f3 rookie 7
rookie 5 and let's call that a clean
advantage for Victor but it's not not
over yet yes ok there's a pop culture
reference in the chance
I know nothing about pop culture alright
I don't know how relevant this is yeah
but I've been told by Jerry stone that
GM jesse looks like clearance from
Robocop is that really earth oh I don't
know Clarence from Robocop I wish I knew
anything about pop culture so I know if
that's true or not mr. Jerry stone you
know my friend el Shan who knows me
quite well it was some picture of me on
social media and he asked the whoever
posted the pictures like is that Carsten
Hanson and I was like what else Shawn do
we all with the same dust white guys
come on I was bald white guys we all
look the same
yeah so I don't know let's just let's
one more peek in then and then we'll end
the show and that is with the famous we
got dar oh man I don't know these are
all set oh this was the game that we
wanted ask the question why does
thinking about it you'd think if he
played Knight be fine and have an idea
for it exactly he's gonna do right now
he might be having second thoughts he
knows he said I'll take back he took
back with me but he's got to choose how
he took with the poor ok there we go
so I don't see I don't see casada losing
the city
yeah definitely looks a little bit
better than what I mean if you just play
b6
it the bummer is your bishop is terrible
you know one funny thing actually point
out is that I could sense way back when
that he didn't want to play f5 it made
sense because you're blocking your
bishop but he had a very specific
purpose and that was to improve the king
he and you got a play f5 before you play
you know before you play king before
else 96 is gonna come and that's f5 is
haunting him here because it's blocking
him in and now the b5 is also blocking
him in so now casada you know in terms
of how you win a tournament it's holding
a game like this it's a big deal
so yeah that's what our fans will be
staying tuned to see what happens in
this big game and before we go I will
say thank you one more time to our
YouTube check that's been fantastic and
we'll finish with one last comment
people are now that they're talking
about our physical appearance yeah
that's fantastic the other guy in the
studio presumably me looks like Woody
Harrelson is what they're saying Woody
Harrelson you're not even bald I know
baby
perhaps they've been seeing Woody
Harrelson who was at the World Chess
Championship big fan of chess don't even
separate the ball from the unbold
we got to give them what they get you
guys have been fantastic and obviously
none of this would be possible without
the world's best B team our who we got
on the board we got to any Machuca Danny
Machuca and we got Isaac doing the the
graphics everything else and they make
this all happen and they run the show
behind the scenes and we got a guy doing
progress than commentary out there don't
forget true so if you're in whatever
area Ben Simon's in look him up I don't
know how to find it I wish I knew we
could plug all of his wrestling stuff
but if you're into the world of rest
check out Ben Simon in next week we're
gonna get a video of Ben Simon in a suit
jumping off the top rope and I'm going
to show that for sure yeah you cannot
miss a day
please join us tomorrow at the same
it will begin for those of us that are
in the central time zone that is 3:30
p.m.
do not listen do not look at the screen
it'll be 3:30 p.m. and you can watch us
again on us chess champs thanks to
everybody for watching it's been a
fantastic show I was very happy to be
here and I look forward to being here
tomorrow at the same time alright I look
forward to
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you